The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: So
I was just going
to be here to answer questions.
AUDIENCE: Just clarifying,
What was the material
that we were covering?
LORNA GIBSON: In the test?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LORNA GIBSON: So the
test covers everything up
to the end of the part
on modeling foams,
but not the bit on the
performance indices,
and the material selection
charts for foams.
So I think up to the end of the
fractured toughness of foams.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK.
So not covering
past [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Not covering
thermal properties, no.
It doesn't cover
thermal properties.
Here you go.
So you know I got
this MacVicar award,
and we had a lunch on Friday
at the Catalyst restaurant.
And I had to get up and speak.
And just as I got
up and spoke, there
was a red-tailed hawk
swooped by the window.
It was perfect.
Yeah.
Hi.
So I'm just here to
answer questions.
So come on.
Somebody must have questions.
It's all perfectly clear?
You want me to do--
AUDIENCE: Talk through test one
from last year a little bit.
LORNA GIBSON: You
would have to give me
test one from last year.
I didn't bring it with me.
I just brought the problem sets.
AUDIENCE: I have
it on my computer,
and I could read
you the problems
or just hand you the laptop.
Whichever you prefer.
LORNA GIBSON: Why don't
you hand me the laptop
and I'll try to do it.
Is that OK?
OK.
So the question is
about the test for 2014.
OK.
So the first question was,
describe four processes
for making honeycombs, and
comment on the type of material
usually used for each process.
So I did post the
solutions, right?
Did you look at that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I looked at them.
I guess I just feel like
I don't fully understand
why things are there.
But I can look at it some more.
LORNA GIBSON: Well, I can
go over it, if you want.
AUDIENCE: I'll just
look at it some more.
LORNA GIBSON: No,
I can go over it.
So four processes.
Let's see.
So there's the expansion
process, where you take sheets
and you glue the
sheets together,
and then you pull them apart.
So you can only really
use that process
for materials that
are going to have
large plastic deformations.
So you could use it for
metals, some polymers.
But you couldn't really
use it for ceramics.
You couldn't use it for
glass because as soon
as you yanked on it, you'd
break the sheets, right?
So--
AUDIENCE: Is it rigid polymers
that you can use it for?
LORNA GIBSON: Well, something
like nylon you can use it for.
Something that's
got a little yield,
that will have some
sort of yield point.
Not like if you had epoxy,
you couldn't use it for epoxy.
So, OK.
So that's one process.
Another process is a
corrugation process
where you have a wheel that
has little gear knobs on it.
And you run your flat
sheet through that
and it comes out with the
half hexagonal profile,
and you glue those together.
So again, you need something
that's going to yield.
So that would
typically be a metal
that you would use that with.
Let's see.
Another processor making
honeycombs is 3D printing.
You can 3D print honeycombs.
And there's different
ways to do it.
One way is by having an ink.
So if you want to print
in ink, typically that's
some sort of polymer
that you're printing.
I suppose physically it's
possible to print glass
or to print a metal,
but you'd have
to have some very high
temperature setup to do that.
So typically a
resin of some sort.
Let's see.
Other ways to make honeycombs.
You can extrude honeycombs.
So the ceramic honeycombs
we saw were made
by extruding a ceramic slurry.
And typically, you would
do that with a ceramic
that's a slurry and a powder.
You wouldn't necessarily
do that with a metal.
I don't think I've seen
any metal honeycombs that
are extruded like that.
OK?
AUDIENCE: OK.
LORNA GIBSON: Are we
good with number one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that makes sense.
LORNA GIBSON: We now
need your password.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
So is there an actual
difference between 3D printing
and the extrusion process?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
So the extrusion you have a die,
and you squeeze the material
through the die, right?
So extrusion's kind of
like the toothpastey thing.
And 3D printing,
you can have an ink
or you can do 3D printing where
you have, let's say, a powder.
And then you print the binder.
And then you heat it up some
way to get the binder to cure.
And then you get rid of the
powder that's not bound.
That's another way to
do the 3D printing.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Can you also
pour it into a mold?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
Yeah, those silicon rubber
honeycombs that I showed you,
those are all made by
pouring a liquid into a mold
and then curing it.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's other ways,
it just asked for four,
so I randomly thought of four.
OK.
OK, are we good?
So the next one is a
hexagonal titanium alloy
honeycomb has h/l is two,
theta is 45, and t/l is 0.05.
It says, the end constraint
factor for elastic buckling
is n equals 0.806.
The titanium has a modulus
of 110 gigapascals,
and yield strength of 880.
And then you have to
calculate some properties.
So would you like me to do that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, you would?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Does anybody
else want that?
LORNA GIBSON: I don't
see a lot of other people
wanting anything else, so
I might as well do that.
Let's see.
I would need a piece of chalk.
Here we go.
OK.
So it's a titanium
alloy honeycomb,
and we're told h/l is 2,
theta's 45, and t/l is 0.05.
And we're told that n-- why
don't I put the n over here-- n
is 0.806.
And we're told the modulus of
the solid is 110 gigapascals,
and the yield strength of the
solid is 880 mega pascals.
OK.
So it says calculate
the value of
and describe the mechanism
of deformation failure
for-- and the first part is
the Young's modulus in the two
direction, e star 2.
OK.
So I don't remember
these formulas either,
so I need to look at my notes.
And oh, I don't have the
formula for e 2 in my notes.
Let me see.
Is it in any of the problems?
AUDIENCE: I have
the formula sheet.
LORNA GIBSON: You have
the formula sheet?
I didn't bring the
formula sheet with me.
You have it?
Yeah, I think it's there.
I'm pretty sure it's there.
OK, so this is just
like substituting,
and there's nothing
complicated about this.
So it's equal to Es times t/l
cubed times h/l plus sine theta
divided by cos cubed theta.
So then you just
plug everything in.
So this is 110 gigapascals.
And I'm going to put
110,000 mega pascals,
because it's probably going
to be less than a gigapascal.
Then t/l is 0.05.
So that's 0.05 cubed.
And then h/l is 2 plus
sign of 45 is 0.707.
And then we divide by cos
theta cubed, 0.707 cubed.
And then I'm not going to
work it out, but that's OK.
I assume that's what's
in the solution.
Are we good?
So it's just substituting.
That's all it is.
In the second part-- OK.
You need to change the time
on this, because it just
keeps timing out.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I don't know
how to change it, but I'll try.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, is
that what this is?
OK, this is the test.
Oh, this is from 2013.
Oh, the next-- if we keep going.
Here we go.
He's got it, so you
take your computer.
AUDIENCE: That's
probably better.
LORNA GIBSON: That's
perfect for everybody.
OK.
The second part is
the plateau stress
for loading in the x2 direction.
So that's that.
For loading in the
x2 direction, it
could either be an
elastic buckling collapse
stress, or a plastic
buckling collapse stress.
So I'm going to
calculate both, and then
whichever one is lower,
that's the one it would be.
So let's see here.
So that's going to be-- I'm
missing my formulas again.
Here we are.
So here's the buckling one.
It's n squared pi squared
over 24 times t cubed over lh
squared times 1 over cos theta.
So you put 0.806
squared in here.
Pi squared 24.
So here you go.
This is t over l cubed
times h over l squared.
So that would be 0.05 cubed.
And that would be 1 over 2
squared, and then 1 over 0.707,
and then whatever that equals.
OK?
Are we good with that?
And then you'd want to
calculate sigma star to plastic.
And that's equal to sigma
ys, t over l squared,
and 1 over 2 cos squared theta.
All right?
So then sigma ys was
880 mega pascals.
And t over l was our 0.05.
And that's 1 over 2
times 0.707 squared,
and then whatever that equals.
OK?
And then whichever one
of those would be less
is the plateau stress.
So I don't-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I know-- I
think I made this mistake
in the problem set, but
here, because it's titanium,
we don't consider it brittle.
LORNA GIBSON: Right.
Right.
I mean, you could.
But you don't need to.
AUDIENCE: That was
something with ceramics?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, or if it was
a glass, or ceramic, or maybe
an epoxy.
Something that was brittle.
And besides which, if
you look at the question,
I only give you a yield
strength and a solid modulus.
So to get the brittle
thing, I would
have to give you a
fracture strength.
AUDIENCE: That's true
with all the problems.
LORNA GIBSON: I usually
give you what you need.
Especially on the
test, I'm going
to give you what you need.
You're not going to
be looking things up.
OK?
So we're good so far?
OK, let me go back
to the question.
So then the third one is the
out of plane Young's modulus
in the x3 direction.
And that's just going to be
Es times the relative density.
And the relative
density-- let's see.
So it's Es times
rho star over rho s.
So that's 110,000 mega pascals.
And then there's also
the very first equation
on this is the relative density.
So it's t/l times h/l
plus 2 divided by 2 cos
theta h/l plus sine theta.
So I'm not going to
substitute everything in, OK?
So that was it.
It was very plug and chug.
Are you good?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question
about a specific question.
LORNA GIBSON: I'm going to
go through the rest of them.
She wants me to
do the whole test.
You want me to do the
whole test, right?
AUDIENCE: That would be
great, but if other people
have other questions it's fine.
LORNA GIBSON: Why don't
I do the whole test.
And then there's going
to be time, I think.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Let me do
the test from last unit.
OK, so that's number one.
Or that's one and two.
And then three is, a closed
cell elastomeric polyethylene
foam has a relative
density of 0.05
and a volume fraction of
solid in the edges of 0.6.
They give you the Young's
modulus of the solid
is 0.2 gigapascals.
The pressure within
the cell walls
is atmospheric,
0.1 mega pascals.
And the Poisson's ratio
of the foam is 0.3.
And you're asked to get the
Young's modulus of the foam,
the compressive plateau stress.
And then there's a
question about why
does the Young's modulus
depend on the solid modulus
and relative density, while
the Poisson's ratio does not.
So let me go through, then.
So the first one
is, what's e star.
And we're told relative
density is 0.05.
The volume fraction
in the edges is 0.6.
So remember, that was
what we called phi.
So phi's 0.6.
The Young's modulus of the
solid is 0.2 gigapascals.
The initial pressure within
the cells is 0.1 mega pascal.
and Poisson's ratio
for the foam is 0.3.
And it's a closed cell.
So if you remember--
oh, let's see.
I think back here,
was I supposed
to-- I was supposed
to say something
about the mechanism
of deformation
and failure for the first one.
So the mechanism of deformation
in the modulus in the 2
direction is bending.
The mechanism of failure
here is buckling.
here is yielding.
And the mechanism of deformation
here was axial deformation, OK?
So I forgot to say that.
OK, let me go back here.
So for this one, if
it's a closed cell foam,
remember there were three
terms to the modulus.
There was one from
bending of the edges, one
from stretching of
the faces, and one
from the gas
contribution if you've
got gas inside the cells.
So again, I'm going to have
to peek at the equation.
Foams.
Here we go, foams.
OK.
And then this gas one.
Get rid of that.
OK, so this one is just
the same kind of thing.
It's just plug and chug.
Do I need to put
all the numbers in?
AUDIENCE: No.
I guess I'm a
little bit confused
why you need the pressure term.
Because you talked
about faces bursting.
LORNA GIBSON: Ah, so if it's the
modulus, remember the modulus--
so the question
is, why do you need
to worry about the
pressure because I talked
about the faces bursting.
And remember, the
stress strain curve
looks something like that.
Maybe the slope of the curve is
a little bit higher over here.
But this is the modulus
down here, right?
The modulus is related to
the initial stress strain
relationship.
And initially, they're
not going to burst.
You'd have to load it up
to some amount of stress
before the faces burst, right?
So when you're down
here, the faces
certainly down at the beginning,
they're not burst, right?
You have to get some stress
before they're going to burst.
And in some materials, when
you get up around here,
around the plateau stress--
let's just call that sigma
star-- then they might burst.
And then the pressure
term would disappear
and the face term
would disappear.
So if I don't tell you to
ignore them, if I don't say
they're going to burst, or I
don't say they're negligible,
I would calculate them.
And then if they're
small, then you say,
well, they're negligible.
OK?
Are we good with that?
You're good?
Sardar, you don't
need to be here.
But you can stay if you want,
but you don't need to be here.
OK, are you good?
Everybody else good?
OK.
That was A. B, what's
the compressive plateau
stress of the foam.
So here, they want to
know what sigma star is.
You're told it's elastomeric.
So if it's elastomeric,
it's like a rubber.
It's rubbery.
So if it's rubbery,
it's going to buckle.
It's not going to yield.
It's not going to be brittle.
So you can just calculate
the elastic stress here.
And if we flip over to our handy
dandy list of equations-- blah,
blah, blah, blah.
Oh, pooh.
I'm realizing--
yeah, so I don't have
the term here for the
faces or for the gas,
so here we could assume
it's going to rupture.
So let's assume it's
going to rupture.
So if we assume that
it's going to rupture,
it would be just like
the open celled foams.
And then you can just use that.
And that's been found to work
fairly well for the open celled
and the closed cell foams.
AUDIENCE: And we assume
that faces rupture because--
LORNA GIBSON:
Well, to be honest,
I can't remember if last year
I got to this point in the test
and somebody said, we
don't have the equation,
and I gave them the equation
with the other terms,
or if we just assumed
that the faces ruptured.
I can't remember.
To be honest, I think
probably for elastomeric foam,
you could assume that they'd
probably don't rupture
unless they're very, very thin.
AUDIENCE: So what kind of foams
do they typically rupture in?
LORNA GIBSON: So certainly
if you had a metal foam,
they'd probably rupture.
If you had, say, a polymer
foam that was more rigid,
like a rigid polyurethane.
So polyurethanes
can be flexible,
which means they're made
out of an elastomer,
or they can be rigid.
And the foams that are
typically used for insulation,
thermal insulation,
are typically
closed celled
polyurethane foams.
And those typically
have very thin faces,
and they would rupture.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you looking
for the Young's modulus
in this problem?
LORNA GIBSON: The
Young's modulus
was the first part, right?
So part A was the
Young's modulus.
AUDIENCE: In B--
LORNA GIBSON: In B is the
collapse stress, the compressor
strength.
AUDIENCE: So I think in my
notes, I think it has this.
If the--
LORNA GIBSON: Right, if p0 is
bigger than-- so what she's
showing me in her notes is I
had a little note in the class,
in the lecture, that if the
initial pressure in the cells
is greater than atmospheric,
then the cell walls are
pre-stressed and you have to
overcome that in the buckling.
AUDIENCE: Is that atmospheric?
LORNA GIBSON: That is
atmospheric pressure.
AUDIENCE: So you don't
need the [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: No.
Yeah.
OK?
OK.
Yeah, you don't know
that that's atmospheric.
So do you ever do things in PSI?
No, you don't.
Because when I was a
student a long time ago,
the thing I remember learning
was atmospheric pressure
is 14.7 PSI, more or less.
And the conversion between
mega pascals and PSI
is there's more or less
145 PSI to a mega pascal,
so the atmospheric pressure
is about 0.1 mega pascals.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
this is a silly question,
but for part B, how do
we get from the Young's
modulus of the foam--
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, sorry,
sorry, sorry, sorry.
I put the wrong thing down here.
Sorry, my mistake.
OK, now you happy?
Sorry.
OK, shall I move on
to the next part?
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Well, I had a
question about number two,
but maybe we can
come back to that--
LORNA GIBSON: OK,
let me finish this,
and then we'll go
back to number two.
So this one here,
the part C is why
does the Young's
modulus foam depend
on the solid modulus
and the relative density
while the Poisson's
ratio does not.
So when I write the equation
for the Young's modulus,
the solid modulus comes into
it, the relative density
comes into it.
And remember when we
had the Poisson's ratio,
it's just a constant that
depends on the cell geometry.
So here's C, nu star
just as a constant.
And that constant just
depends on the cell geometry.
So if you think of
the Poisson's ratio,
it's the ratio of
two strains, right?
So say I have my foam here.
So say that's just
a block of foam.
Little cells in it here.
Little cells.
And say I press on
it this way here.
And let's call this
the one direction
and the two direction.
If I press it in
the two direction,
the Poisson's ratio is
then just nu would be--
let's see, this would be 2, 1.
It'd be the strain
in the one direction
over the strain in
the two direction.
So it's the ratio of
two strains, right?
And if you think of our model
for the elastic behavior
of the foam, each
of those strains
is going to be related to some
bending deformation in the cell
walls or the cell struts.
And this strain here
is going to be--
let me make this proportional.
It's going to be proportional
to a delta over l.
And this one here is
going to be proportional
to the delta over l.
So this might be delta
in the one direction,
and this will be delta
in the two direction.
But those two things
are both going
to be related to the bending
deflection of the beams, right?
And since both of
those deltas are
related to the bending
deflection of the beams,
we could write
them-- if you want,
I could write that as f l cubed
over E of the solid times t
to the fourth.
And then that's times 1 over l.
And then this thing here is also
f l cubed over E of the solid t
to the fourth 1 over l.
So everything cancels out
except the geometrical constant.
And if you remember when
we did the honeycombs,
it looked exactly the same.
When we looked at the Poisson's
ratio of the honeycombs,
we had the strain
in one direction
over the strain in
another direction.
And each of those
strains was related
to some component of delta.
There was a delta
1 and a delta 2.
But the delta 1 might
be delta sine theta
and delta 2 was delta cos theta.
So if the deltas are the same,
then it all just cancels out.
And all you're left with
is a geometrical constant.
OK?
Do you get physically
why that is?
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question about this.
Because we're given most of
the equations that we need,
is it only in
conceptual questions
that we should know how we
actually derived that version?
LORNA GIBSON: I'm
not going to ask
you to derive that equation
for a closed cell foam.
AUDIENCE: I meant
this last part.
LORNA GIBSON: Well yeah, you
should be able to explain that.
But I mean just at this level.
Nothing very
mathematically involved.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
LORNA GIBSON: OK, are we good?
So that was the end of the test
for the undergraduates, OK?
And then for the
graduate students,
just like the problem sets, I
just have an extra question.
And that's what I
did this year, too.
So the graduate students
have one extra question.
So you and you.
Is anybody else a
graduate student?
I think it's just
the two of you.
You're post post-graduate.
OK.
So let's see.
So this one says,
the performance--
so this is on the performance
indices which I told you
you didn't need to know for this
test, partly because, remember,
we missed two lectures.
We're not exactly on the same
spot as we were last year.
But I can do it if you want.
Do you want me to do it, or
should we do other questions?
AUDIENCE: What do the
grad students think?
LORNA GIBSON: Sure.
OK.
So the question is,
the performance index
to minimize the mass of a beam
of a given bending stiffness,
length and square cross-section
is e to the one half over rho.
So you remember, we derived
that e to the one half
over rho in class.
In the section on wood, we saw
that this performance index
for wood is higher than
that for the solid cell wall
material in wood.
Do you remember that?
The e to the one half over
rho for the wood was, I think,
rho s over rho star to
the one half times Es
to the one half over rho s.
So explain why wood
has a higher value of e
to the one half over rho than
the solid cell wall material.
And then part B is, suggest
a design for an engineering
material based on wood
that has high values of e
to the one half over rho.
So one way to explain it is to
say that if you're looking at e
to the one half over rho, you
can say for wood, E over Es
is equal to rho star
over rho s for loading
in the axial direction.
So this will be for loading
actually along the grain.
And that's what we
were looking at.
So that's what I'm
talking about here.
So I think-- let me just
see if this is right.
Yeah.
So this equation here is exactly
the same as that equation
there, right?
And this is basically saying
that this is the performance
index for the wood.
This is the performance
index for the solid.
And this factor here
is bigger than 1,
because the solid density is
higher than the wood density.
OK?
So really, all you have to
do is say that for the wood,
the modulus in the longitudinal
or the axial direction
along with grain varies linearly
with the relative density.
And it probably
would be a good idea
to say that this is a result
of the cell walls deforming
axially.
So when you take the cells,
if you think of the wood cells
as being something like that and
you're loading it this way on,
the cells just actually
shorten, and the modulus
depends on the-- it just is the
volume fraction of solid times
the modulus of the solid.
And that's where
this comes from.
And once you have this, that
basically gives you that.
OK?
Are we good with that?
So that's why it's higher.
Another way to
look at it as sort
of more of a
hand-wavy argument is
that if you have a
certain amount of solid--
so say you have a
certain mass of solid.
If it's solid, it takes up a
certain cross-sectional area.
So say that your beam's
a certain length, that's
going to have a certain
cross-sectional area.
And if you have wood, if you
have a cellular material,
if you have the
same mass, you're
essentially making the
dimensions of that piece
bigger.
So you're moving the
material further away.
And as you're making
it bigger, you're
increasing the
moment of inertia.
And so you're increasing the
bending resistance of it.
That's another, more hand-waving
way to talk about it.
And then the second
part is to suggest
a design for an
engineering material
based on wood that would
have high values of e
to the one half over rho.
So remember when we looked
at those material performance
charts, we said that wood was
similar to engineering fiber
composites.
But those data for
fiber composites
are assuming that it's solid,
the fiber composite's a solid.
So if you could take
fiber composites
and make little tubes
of fiber composites
and assemble the tubes together
so that it was like wood,
would get something that
would be even higher.
So if you could make, say,
a fiber composite honeycomb
material, and you'd want
to have the fibers aligned
along the prism axis
of the honeycomb,
then you would
get higher values.
It would be the same-- it'd be
this sort of argument again,
but now with a fiber composite.
So you'd want-- if this was
your fiber composite like this,
you'd want the
fibers-- well, in wood,
they're at a little
bit of an angle.
But say they were
lined up like that.
You'd want them
something like that,
then loading it
that way on, right?
And if one way to think
about those charts
is if you-- say we had a plot.
And say this was
log of the modulus
and that was log of the density.
And I think I'll just
draw the envelope.
So foams were
somewhere down here,
metals were somewhere over
here, and with elastomers we're
somewhere in here.
I think ceramics were up here.
And then I can't remember
exactly where composites were,
but composites were
around about here.
I'll just say FRC for fiber
reinforced composites.
And I think woods
were kind of in here.
Something like that.
And then we had our
performance index, right?
So remember, there was
a performance index,
something like that.
And that slope of that was
e to the one half over rho.
So every point on that line
had the same value of e
to the one half over rho.
And essentially, if you
had the fiber composite
and you made a
honeycomb out of it,
you would be taking
the data from here
and shifting them out that way.
You'd be pushing
them out over here,
so you'd get a higher value
of that performance index.
OK?
So that's the test
from last year.
That's the end-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So for
along right here
or different it would be cubed.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, so the
thing about the honeycombs is--
AUDIENCE: The opposite.
LORNA GIBSON: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: It'd be
worse, that's true.
So the thing about
the honeycombs
is they're very stiff
in the axial direction,
but you pay for that in
the other directions.
And it's the same for wood.
So the wood is very good when
you load it along the grain,
but you pay for
it the other way.
But if you think of from
the tree's point of view--
if you're a tree.
So here's my little tree.
So here, say we have a tree
trunk, and we have some branch.
Branch over here,
branches, tree.
So the grain is
lined up this way.
And then when there's
a branch, the grain
turns around and
goes that way, right?
So if you think of
the tree as a whole,
the whole tree blows
in the wind like this.
So it's like a column like
this, and everything's
lined up that way.
And you're loading it this way.
So that is the stiff
direction, right?
And if you're a
branch, the branches
are more loaded by gravity.
So they're loaded that way.
And then because the fibers,
the grain turns around,
they're also oriented
in the good direction.
So from the tree's point of
view, it's optimized things.
Then you remember when I talked
about the old wooden sailing
ships, when they made
the old wooden sailing
ships, if this was the deck here
and that was the haul there,
they would get pieces
of wood to fit in here
that were called the knees.
That was the knee.
And they would try
to get a piece that
was from a branch like this.
And they would try to match
the curve of that joint
with the branch with the curve
that they needed in here so
that the grain followed
the pattern of what
they needed for the boat.
OK.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I'm not
quite sure what
the difference between
tangential versus ray here.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, OK.
So in the wood, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
So can I rub this stuff off?
We're happy?
Let's see.
Say again?
So tangential and radial.
OK.
So say the wood cells
look something like this.
So these would be the fiber
cells or the tracheids
And then the rays typically
are more rectangular cells.
So they might look
something like that.
And then they would be some
more fibers or tracheids,
depending on if it was a
soft wood or a hardwood.
So these would be either
fibers or tracheids
in a hardwood or a soft wood.
And then these would be
the ray cells in here.
So they have a
different structure.
They just look different.
They're different shape.
AUDIENCE: This is the top?
From the top?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, this is
looking from the top down.
And then if you
think of the tree--
so the tree's going to
have growth rings, right?
So the growth rings are
going to look-- obviously
I'm not making perfect
circles, but you get
the idea-- something like that.
And then the rays go this way.
They go radially.
OK?
So this would be the
radial direction,
and then those are the rays.
Are we good?
AUDIENCE: So which
way's the tangential?
LORNA GIBSON: So the tangential
would be this way on, OK?
So if I loaded
this way like that,
that would be loading it in
the tangential direction.
And if I loaded
it this way, that
would be loading it in
the radial direction.
The length of the rays runs
in the radial direction.
The length this way on.
So this thing here
corresponds to one
of these lines I've drawn here.
And then these guys here are
the stuff in between here.
AUDIENCE: How do you know what
the tangential, the Young's
modulus and stiffness is?
LORNA GIBSON: So say we were
loading it tangentially,
we're loading it like that.
Then--
AUDIENCE: If you have
a tree, how do you
apply a tangential load on it?
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, well it's
not the whole tree, right?
So say we have a piece of wood
that we cut out like this.
So say I have that.
And if I loaded it this way on,
I'd be loading it tangentially.
The tree's big, right?
So I'm not talking about
loading the whole tree,
I'm talking about taking a
piece of wood out of the tree
and loading it.
AUDIENCE: OK, so you can't
really load tangentially
for the entire trunk.
LORNA GIBSON: No, I'm talking
about taking a piece out
and loading that piece.
AUDIENCE: How about a ray here?
Do you take the--
LORNA GIBSON: So the same thing.
You'd take-- say this
was the piece of wood
that you were looking at.
Now you would just
load it this way on.
OK?
I think-- I brought my thing
because I have the slides.
Let me see if I can
find-- I think there
was a slide that showed this.
OK.
That was Furry Fridays.
That was the wood sculptor.
Here we go.
OK, so imagine that that
cube is your piece of wood
that you're loading, right?
So imagine this is the--
you cut a little piece out.
Then you're loading it tangent.
Can you see, then?
You can load it-- you're
not loading the whole tree.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was thinking
about loading the entire tree
and then applying the
tangential load on it.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, because
then-- I see the problem.
AUDIENCE: It's going
to give us shears.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
Yeah, because I could
say, well, if I was
trying to load the whole thing.
Say I was loading it
from here to there.
Well if you look at it one
way, it looks tangential.
If you look at it the
other way, it looks radial.
So think of cutting a
piece out, because that
is what you're going to do.
You're going to cut a piece out.
OK?
All right.
Are there other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: With
that formula sheet,
do you only give that
formula for the honeycombs,
or also for the foams?
LORNA GIBSON: I'm going to give
you-- if you look at, I think,
problem set 2, I
gave you a sheet that
had three pages of equations.
And it looked exactly like this.
So there was one
saying, properties
of two dimensional cellular
solids-- honeycombs.
There was a whole thing
of in plane properties
and out of plane properties.
That was one page.
The next page was properties of
regular hexagonal honeycombs.
And then the next
page was properties
of three dimensional
cellular solids foams.
AUDIENCE: OK, excellent.
Thank you.
LORNA GIBSON: OK?
Like I just said,
I think there's
maybe one or two equations
missing from this.
But if it was something you
needed, I would give it to you.
I would give it to you.
OK?
AUDIENCE: So I should
have scrolled down for it?
LORNA GIBSON: What?
You should have scrolled?
So you're like me.
This happens to me all the time.
I have some website.
I'm looking at it.
I'm like, OK.
I got it.
I think I've got everything.
And then I realized I'm
supposed to-- I missed something
because I was supposed
to scroll down.
AUDIENCE: Problem set two
was only the honeycombs.
That's why.
LORNA GIBSON: Well, I
think that was probably
all we covered was the
honeycombs on that problem set.
AUDIENCE: So that's why
I only got that part.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
All right, yeah.
So I'm going to give you, this
will be attached to the test.
OK?
So I think on the test that
I posted it was attached,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE], did
you have a question?
AUDIENCE: For 2 part D, I
don't think we went over that.
I was confused as
to how-- is it just
that equilateral triangular
cells always have-- is always
truss behavior?
LORNA GIBSON: Let's see.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
It's the 2014 test.
LORNA GIBSON: 2014-- oh, sorry.
I missed a part.
Sorry.
Yeah, so it says, the
same titanium alloy
is used to make a honeycomb with
equilateral triangular cells.
And what is the in
plane Young's modulus
for loading in the x 2 direction
of the triangular honeycomb?
So this is-- say you have
cells that look like that now.
And that's x 1.
That's x 2.
OK.
So the Young's
modulus for this--
so I happen to
remember the formula.
So I guess I'm
thinking you might have
put this on your cheat sheets.
It's 1.15 times Es times that,
times the relative density.
So I'm trying to remember.
Do I have that on here?
I don't have it on here.
AUDIENCE: Are we just
supposed to know that?
Are we just supposed to--
LORNA GIBSON: Well,
I guess what I
would hope that you would know
is maybe not the constant,
but that it should
go as Es and linearly
with the relative density.
Because it's a truss and
because it deforms axially.
I don't really expect that
you would remember the 1.15.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So does that mean for
all the foams, of which there
were like 10 constants, we
don't need to write all down,
like what C1 equals--
LORNA GIBSON: I think that's
what this thing gives you.
Let's see.
It gives you all the Cs.
All right, then I'll make
sure I give you the Cs.
I'll make sure I
give you the Cs.
But who's got a pen so I can
write that down to make sure
that I do that?
Does somebody got
a piece of paper.
Or I could write it down here.
Oh, here we go.
I can write it down this
little sticky thing here.
OK.
So I'll stick that on there
so I remember to do that.
AUDIENCE: Will you also
be writing what Cs?
Because you have, in
your equation, C1, C2--
LORNA GIBSON: Well,
I think I would
say-- say I asked you
for, I don't know,
the yield stress for
a foam in compression
that yields plastically.
I would say, the
constant for that is 0.3.
I wouldn't give you C2.
I wouldn't do it by
numbers, I would tell you
what the number was for
the thing you needed,
because I mean the
way the numbers are,
the only reason
they're numbered is
because that's the number
they are in the book.
They're just ordered
sequentially in the book.
But I don't expect you
to remember which--
it's C6, or C5 or something.
So anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain the difference
between uniaxial yield
and plastic buckling?
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, OK.
So if you have something and
it fails by uniaxial yield--
so say you have a
honeycomb like this,
and you're loading
it this way on, OK?
So if you're loading
it that way on,
these walls of the honeycomb
are just axially deforming,
initially.
Right?
So the elastic behaviors,
they just axially deform.
So it works out that if these
cell walls are very thick, then
you can reach a yield stress
before any buckling occurs.
And then the strength would
just be that yield stress
of the cell wall material
times the relative density.
OK?
But the cell walls have to
be thick for that to happen.
So then imagine that the
cell walls aren't thick.
Imagine that the
cell walls are thin.
So say I have the same
honeycomb like this.
If the walls are thin,
and say the solid material
itself-- so this is
for the solid-- it
has some stress strain curve.
And it may have a linear
elastic part, and then
a yield thing like that.
So say this is the
yield strength here.
Say we compress that this way
on the same thing in the three
direction.
Then if a material's
got a yield point,
there can be an
interaction between plastic
yielding and elastic buckling.
And you can get
plastic buckling.
And the plastic
buckling, you're going
to get the wrinkles
that go along
the length of it this way.
remember I showed you that
tube that kind of collapsed
and folded up kind of thing?
That's plastic buckling.
OK?
And typically, people use what's
called the tangential modulus
to calculate the buckling
stress for plastic buckling.
And the tangential modulus
would be something related
to the tangent over there.
I don't expect you
to be able to derive
plastic buckling equations.
But the plastic
buckling-- you know what
elastic buckling is, right?
Yeah.
So one way to think
about plastic buckling
is, if you have-- and
I'm trying to remember.
This is called the
slenderness ratio.
And I'm trying to
remember, is that l over r?
Imagine you had just a
circular cross section
and you had a length, l.
So you have a column here,
and it's got a length, l,
and it's got a radius, r.
Like that, OK?
So the longer it gets,
the more slender it is,
the higher the
slenderness ratio is.
And this, I think, is
some sort of stress.
If the slenderness ratio
of just a single column
is short-- if it's
stubby, if you
had a column that looked
kind of like that,
It's not going to buckle.
It's going to yield.
And so if you compress
that, it would just yield.
And it's just going to yield
at the yield stress, right?
It's just going to yield at
sigma y of the solid, whatever
the solid is.
If you have a long column,
it would buckle elastically
by an Euler buckling.
And Euler buckling-- let's see.
I'm going to run
out of room here.
If you think of it in terms
of a stress instead of a load,
it's going to be in
squared pi squared Es i.
Let's say i goes
as r to the fourth.
And this is going to
be l squared r squared.
Right?
This is going to
be a pi in here.
There's going to
be a pie in here.
I might have lost a
factor of 4, but it's
going to be-- let me make
this proportional, OK?
So the slenderness
ratio, there's
going to be an l over
r squared term here.
So I could cancel out the
four there and put a squared.
So sigma Euler is going to go
as Es times r over l squared.
Like that.
And so this is the Euler
buckling stress here, OK?
So this would be elastic.
And right here at
this little corner,
it turns out life isn't quite
that mathematically exact.
If you're near that
corner, it's not
like here it's
buckling elastically,
and here, it's
buckling plastically.
What happens is, if
you looked at data,
data might do
something like that.
So the sum interaction between
the elastic and the plastic.
And that's kind of what's
going on with this thing here.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Plastic
buckling can-- OK,
so if you unload
plastic buckling,
you get some of the
elastic part back?
LORNA GIBSON: You're not
going to get much back.
AUDIENCE: You're not?
LORNA GIBSON: No, because once--
to get the plastic buckling,
you're very close to this.
By the time you get
that deformation,
you've got locally,
it's yielded.
It's not all elastic everywhere.
It's going to yield in places.
And once it starts yielding,
it's-- if you think of these
buckles forming, it's not like
you're at one spot on this
curve throughout
the whole thing.
Some of it's more deformed,
and some of it's less deformed.
Let me pull up those plastically
buckled columns, those tubes.
Get rid of that one.
Let me try and remind
myself where they were.
I think-- honeycombs,
I want honeycombs.
Out of plane,
that's what I want.
It was this thing here.
So you see when you have--
that's just one tube,
but the whole honeycomb
would-- imagine that you have
groups of tubes put together.
They would have to fail
in some compatible way.
But the deformation
and the stresses
are not going to be uniform
through this whole thing,
right?
One part of it's going
to be at one stress,
and something else is going
to be at another stress.
So parts of it are going
to yield plastically,
and you're not going
to recover that.
OK?
So in fact, they use these sorts
of things for energy absorption
devices, like in cars
and things like that.
To absorb the energy
from the impact.
More questions?
Let him have a turn.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I have a
question about I think 2013.
LORNA GIBSON: 2013, OK.
AUDIENCE: The last question.
It's about the plastic.
LORNA GIBSON: 2013.
Let me rub some
of this stuff off.
OK.
Here we go.
Oh, we haven't
covered this at all.
So the last question,
this one here?
AUDIENCE: Right.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah,
so this question's
on energy absorption.
We haven't got there yet.
AUDIENCE: How about-- OK.
LORNA GIBSON: And
the third question's
on sandwich structure.
So when I taught
the course in 2013,
I did the topics in
a different order.
So I did honeycombs,
and I did foams.
And then I think I
did sandwich panels,
and I did energy absorption.
And I left the stuff on the
wood and the cork to the end.
So we haven't done that.
So don't panic if you
haven't-- if you can't do that.
OK?
You should have known.
Come on, you should have known
that if it talked about things
we haven't covered yet, I'm not
going to give it on the test.
OK, what else?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
more plastic hinges?
LORNA GIBSON: Plastic hinge, OK.
So let's just say we have
a beam in bending, OK?
And say it just has a load
p in the middle, all right?
Are we good?
So this load in the middle,
then this reaction is p over 2,
and that reaction is p over 2.
And if I drew the sheer force
diagram, it'd go p over 2 up,
we go over, go p over 2
down, like 2 p over 2 down.
Over and back up.
OK?
And then if I drew the
bending moment diagram,
it would go up and
down like that.
And that would be zero.
And this would be PL over 4.
OK?
Are we OK with that?
We haven't got to the
end of the answer, but--
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
We're not expected to--
LORNA GIBSON: No, no, you
don't need to do this.
I'm just trying
to explain it now.
You don't need to
retain that information,
for heaven's sakes.
No.
Come on, I'm so disappointed.
AUDIENCE: For the
moment, is it positive
for the counterclockwise turns?
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, so you
remember for the beam bending,
there's a different convention.
It's positive if it's
tension on the bottom.
Are you in mechanical
engineering?
I though you were in
mechanical engineering.
AUDIENCE: No, I take physics.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh,
you do physics.
All I really want to say is the
moment's maximum in the middle,
OK?
So let me just say the moment's
maximum in the middle, OK?
So then let's look
at the cross section.
So say I look at a
cross section here.
Let's just make it rectangular
to make it easy for me to draw.
So it has width,
b, and a height, h.
OK?
So this would be h on
this picture over here.
And remember, the neutral
axis goes through the middle
on the cross-section here.
And so one half of the
beam is in tension,
and the other half of the
beam is in compression.
So for this situation
here, this half of the bean
is going to see compression,
and that half of the beam
is going to see tension, OK?
Are we happy with that?
We're happy with that.
OK.
Now let me draw the
stress distribution.
So if it's linear elastic
and it hasn't yielded yet,
the stress distribution is
going to look like this.
So this is h again.
That's the height.
And now b is into the board.
And I'm plotting
the stress this way.
So this thing here
is my neutral axis.
It has no stress.
Remember, there was one
plane that has no stress,
and for a rectangular
cross-section,
it goes through the middle
of the cross-section.
It goes through the centroid.
Is this ringing a bell?
I'm hoping this
is ringing a bell.
Come on.
I know we did this in 302, too.
I know we did.
OK.
OK, so this is all
linear elastic, right?
So at some point-- so I'm going
to get to the plastic hinge.
At some point, If
you keep loading it
and p gets bigger and
bigger, the moment
gets bigger and bigger, the
stress gets bigger and bigger
remember, the equation
here for the stress
is equal to My over i.
This moment, the
maximum moment's
going to be this moment here.
The maximum y is going to
be h over 2, the distance
from the neutral axis.
And i is going to
be bh cubed over 12
for the rectangular section.
So if I keep loading
it up, at some point,
the maximum stress is going
to equal the yield stress.
right?
And in our cellular
things, is going
to equal the yield
stress of the solid.
So our beam is one of
our edges in the foam,
or struts in the honeycomb.
So at some point, is
going to equal the yield
strength of the solid.
So let me draw the stress
distribution again,
where we start to
have plasticity.
So here, the stress is
equal the yield stress.
And it's going to equal the
yield stress at the bottom,
too, because it's
all symmetric, right?
And the neutral axis is still
going to be in the middle here.
So it's going to 0 down there.
So initially, when it's just
barely reached the yield stress
at the outer part of the beam,
then this stress distribution
would still be
linear in between.
But once you start to
load it more than that,
then the plastic region
starts to seep in
from the outside inwards.
And what we do here is we
assume that the solid is
elastic perfectly plastic.
And if you remember, when we
said things were perfectly
plastic, or if they were
elastic perfectly plastic,
they look like that.
The stress strain curve for
the solid, I'm assuming,
looks like that.
So I'm assuming the
yield stress in the solid
is just a constant.
That if I strain it more,
there's no work hardening.
I'm neglecting work hardening.
AUDIENCE: You said
inward that the--
LORNA GIBSON: In board?
AUDIENCE: Inward, you
said something like--
LORNA GIBSON: Inward.
So this is-- let's see.
I didn't bring a
bean with me today.
No beam.
Do we have anything beam-like?
Ah, here we have
a beam-like thing.
OK.
So say this is my beam, and
I'm loading it this way on, OK?
And this is b, and that's h.
So this picture here is
looking at it that way on, OK?
And this picture
here, I've drawn h,
but now I'm just looking at the
stress distribution across h.
And b is into the board.
Is that OK?
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: No, I mean
for the plastic.
LORNA GIBSON: For this part?
OK.
I'm working up.
I haven't finished it yet.
So this is the same
kind of view as here.
I drew it a little bigger.
It shouldn't have
draw bigger, I should
have drawn it the same height.
But it's the same thing.
OK?
So you'll buy that
at some point,
we reach the yield
strength here.
And if I keep
loading it up and I
assume that the solid
is perfectly plastic,
that there's no work hardening,
then the stress distribution
would look like this.
OK?
And then if it yields more, then
it's going to look like that.
And if it yields more,
eventually I'm going to get
to the stage here, where
it's-- let me redraw this.
That would be-- you
get the idea, OK?
This will go over here, and
down here, and like that.
OK?
OK.
So are we happy with
this stress distribution
across the cross-section?
Yeah, OK.
So that's when it forms
the plastic hinge.
So when it forms
a plastic hinge,
the stress distribution
looks like this.
So these are supposed
to be the same size.
They're not quite.
Let's see.
So one of the things
I talked about
was the plastic moment
that kind of characterized
that plastic hinge.
And the plastic moment is just
the internal amount of moment
that the beam can withstand
when it's yielded completely
across the whole cross-section.
So when we're at
this point here.
So you calculate that
by saying, that stress
there is equivalent to a force.
That stress there is
equivalent to a force.
And you get the moment by
multiplying those forces
times that distance there.
OK?
Because you think of those
two forces as being a couple,
and the moments the force times
the distance between them.
So the plastic
moment was sigma ys.
And say we're talking about our
honeycomb or foam or something.
That was our cell
wall thickness t.
So let me call it t
instead of h for the foams
and the honeycombs.
So this force here is going
to be the stress time the area
over which it acts.
And let's say we look
at it for a honeycomb.
Then I've got the stress is
acting over this distance
here, and then times the
depth into the page, right?
And if it's the honeycomb,
that depth into the page
is just b, OK?
And then this moment arm
here is just t over 2
as well, because that's t
over 4, and that's t over 4.
So it's t over 2 again.
So it's sigma ys bt squared
over 4 for the honeycomb.
And say we have
an open cell foam.
The edges aren't of thickness
b, they're of thickness t.
So then it's m p is just
sigma ys t cubed over 4.
Are we happy?
And really, physically
what that is is it
means that the beam can't
hold any more force.
You can't apply any
more force to it.
It's just going to rotate
like this once you've
gotten to that plastic moment.
That's why it's called
a hinge, because it just
can rotate like hinge rotates.
Like a door hinge, OK?
AUDIENCE: How does it rotate?
LORNA GIBSON: Well, where's
my original picture.
So if this was the beam, when
you form the plastic hinge,
your beam would
just look like that.
And this would be
your hinge point.
I'm a civil engineer originally.
We try to avoid this.
So that's why, in the foam
and in the honeycomb, that's
when it fails is when you get
that plastic hinge forming.
OK?
All right.
We have a few more minutes.
AUDIENCE: That kind of
looks like plastic buckling.
LORNA GIBSON: Well yeah, it's
not buckling, but it's plastic,
yeah.
It's permanent.
Anyone else?
OK.
No other questions?
Should we call it a day?
Is that helpful?
All right, then.
It's what I do.
Come on.
All right.
So I'll see you Wednesday.
And my plan is to grade the
tests before spring break,
so I shall have it back to you.